bello a tutti ragazzi ebbene tutto
questo nuovo video sono dj ed oggi
stiamo sul charter 2014 che cazzo è
partito
[Musica]
da cruz
dalle urne
beh ragazzi questo episodio di già
stessi sarà un pezzo speciale che
vedrete a fine vita o dopo le prime due
canzoni ma tanto ve lo siete già
schierati col titolo quindi iniziamo
perché ciò voglia di ballare
[Musica]
lega stavolta ci voglio andare sul
pesante subito perché mi avete
consigliato due canzoni che sono a san
polo questa che la posso fatidica farò
mai ci ha fatto fare bene donna
d'onna cazzo non ce l'ho e assistiamo
così tutto il video
si sono attaccate incredibile erano
difficili ma non pensavo anche a
selezionarle cazzo mi avete detto questa
è poi quella che farà dopo e poi
l'ultima è la speciale ma non mi
spiegano nulla perché vi siete già è
quella di tutto cominciamo perché sono
pronto ragazzi mi sento carico c'è
la fortezza
belli
ci avete preso in pieno raga
niente le bugie
[Musica]
cosa ne dici ragazzo io mio ok ci sono
basta la cassa canzone di mazzone anche
ma chi se ne frega eccoci
[Musica]
[Applauso]
qua e così donna che vuoi vedere che
forse riusciamo a fare ragazzi siamo
troppo sexy
[Musica]
sulla stella grazie a dio
mio dio che cosa sexy ragazze una
[ __ ] stella e mi piazzo cazzo mio dio
sono distrutto lei sa che ne direste se
facessi una canzone con la maschera di
psyco sarebbe la cosa piu figo del mondo
secondo ci voglio provare perdo non
abbiate mai visto mi chico che balla
perché diciamo che potreste rimanere
seriamente traumatizzati vabbè poi tutti
si sono pronto mio dio cos'è 23 stiamo
sull'himalaya che cazzo ragazzi stiamo
giocando a sky just dance aspettate un
attimo scusate ci vedo male questa
maschera chiesto casinò farli ballare
[Musica]
dopo
ha provato
sono esageratamente pezzi rosa maschera
tre mosse
[Musica]
cosa
io scusa di una donna brano mio zio mi
sappia farlo tutto
il ragazzo
[Musica]
non basta nata donna fermata
ma così si calma calma calma
ok ok
ringraziando iddio è finita ok ragazzi
adesso devo devo fargli un discorso
serio aspettate un attimo vuoi sapete
siete a conoscenza delle mie doti da
ballerino ma immaginate se tutto questo
avvenisse su un palco davanti alle
persone il live che cosa potrebbe
succedere
a voi i commenti
[Applauso]
così
sì
o
forse sì
[Musica]
corso
e anche
può fare il giornalista
[Musica]
va di moda l'uomo disoccupato e il miur
i dati agli occhi della polizia di stato
e per i manifestanti il castorio parlare
l'euro
di landro
parecchio
le signorine
ci sono i compagni o ti senti sempre
sono circolare il miglior amico
dell'uomo
destinata
la crisi
sì sì
città
[Musica]
no
con la pelle liscia 20 tel aviv e alla
povertà è fondamentale per la linea
appellandosi
per i fatti legati
sì
e vietata
[Musica]
non va bene
di tranquillizzarmi con qualcosa perché
lo piccolo
giorno si scusa